next manga three by three and we have
beer yeah we have beer
this just appears cheers boys
cheers cheers oh it's been a very
civilized three by three so far but i
mean what what can we complain about
this honestly normie yeah
is it normie though
i kinda i'd say it's pretty normal
i don't know man
listen ain't nothing wrong with a bit of
boy's love you know that's as normal as
it gets who's next
which of you wants to go next
i don't mind going next you don't want
you don't want to go i don't mind going
next all right let's see what joey has
to say this might be oh no okay why is
that so tight
[Music]
hold on
joey oh it's me oh okay i actually
thought this was gone
i could have sworn i folded god's tiny
that no this is not fixed i just
i'm just saying
you're exposing us connor you're
exposing us scripted
this is joey too
it was destiny there was two cherries
that was not me
i swear we did not when i asked him he
wanted to go next i that was not fixed
this is like the google when people
search up what is goku's real name
it was rigged but whatever we'll have
joey's up next i guess oh
okay do i know all of these okay let me
try and guess this all right so berserk
obviously i guess you put jojoba six
specifically yeah i like part 6
specifically
um
do you know this one is that is that
misa from death note is that
is it
do you recognize i kind of recognize
this
is the assassins thing assassin's thing
no that's hitman reborn
this is this was a [ __ ]
it's a shonen it's shiny jump yeah black
cat it's black
i've seen the anime black yes very good
is it mr manga good yeah it's [ __ ]
awesome wait why did the anime suck dick
i don't know i didn't watch the anime
what the hell this is
here listen i'm not sure
this is a manga iii i've seen this i
think
this is this is the line rider right
that mini click
he's the main character
yeah he's the main character and
everyone else is a normally drawn
character yeah okay and then yeah
and then slam dunk b stars
um joe love room
we bought the whole collection of
television recently right yeah
accidentally
you want to explain the story
yeah
so i got scammed quote unquote so i
bought uh i bought
all the volumes of boba bo which was one
that i thought about putting up here um
but it was only volume one and four
though so basically i opened up volume
one and it was uh i bought a second hand
so i was like okay i was whatever it was
chiefs or whatever and i was like all
right cool i'm gonna relieve my
childhood open up volume one of bobo
it's volume three of twelve
they just literally replaced the cover
i'm not scared
they literally just put the cover
of bobo
on the front of this but it's volume
three of the locker room did you reckon
they did it on purpose or an accident i
reckon it's by accident so i was like
wait don't tell me all of these at all
for some reason volume one and four was
so so it's probably just you know you
know when you like take a dvd out to
watch it and you have to put the dvd in
the dvd player back in the box yeah i
think you forget that you've just like
yeah
was owned by like a teenager and it was
like well i need to hide the
degenerative [ __ ] from my mom i'm going
to put the bow before oh my god that was
totally it wasn't it was so yeah
they'll never know we'll never know i
don't ever know i just think it's
barbara some kids jacked off dior
volume 1. i'm trying to throw that out
uh is this junji eater so that's uzumaki
oh yeah it's this i'd be surprised you
know it's ichigo 100 oh it's itchy i've
heard of this i have not read it or
watched it okay um